-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show" starring
one of the Jimmys.
Boy, are my kids going
to be confused
when Jimmy Fallon picks them up
from school today.
[ Laughter ]
Tonight is Friday, which,
as you know,
if you watch the show,
is when Jimmy likes to catch up
on personal stuff.
And, since there are so many
people to thank,
I thought I might take some time
to write some thank-you notes.
Is that okay with everybody?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Alright.
I've got a pen.
I've got notes.
James, may I have some --
Yes, oh, yes.
[ Playing tender tune ]
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Never seen him smile.
-James is
the one person happier
that I'm here.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Alright.
-Dang.
-Here we go.
Thank you, "The Tonight Show,"
for letting me switch spots
with Jimmy today
and for letting me eat
all the food marked...
...in the office fridge.
[ Laughter ]
Half a chicken Parm,
and it was delicious.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Jimmy Fallon,
for leaving me this copy
of your 2005 megahit
"Fever Pitch" on VHS.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I fast-forwarded
right to the sex parts.
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy, surprisingly,
not a hair on his bottom.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no.
-Thank you, New York City,
for being
The City That Never Sleeps.
Though it does sometimes
take a nap
after it masturbates
on the subway.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You get that, right, Higgins?
Yeah.
-Oh, I get it.
-Thank you, Cracker Jacks,
for letting us experience
what candy
in the Great Depression
tasted like.
[ Laughter ]
Though you do get a toy.
-You get a toy.
You get a toy.
-Don't trust the candy that has
to give you a toy.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Dr. Scholl's,
for dedicating your life to feet
without being a pervert
about it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Feet.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you,
couples with a Sleep Number Bed,
for coming up with a simple way
to tell the world,
"We stopped having sex
ten years ago."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you, Matt Damon,
for reminding us that,
if you set your mind to it,
you can win an Oscar for writing
even when you can't read.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
That's true.
It's amazing, though.
-Yeah.
-And, finally,
thank you, April Fools' Day,
for being the one day
of the year
I can steal "The Tonight Show"
without first promising it
to Conan.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
There you go.
I'm done with "Thank You Notes."
You're welcome.
We'll be back with Hugh Jackman.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Yeah ♪
Ha ha!
♪ Just to let you know ♪